- Do you know how much
you earn in consulting?
This video is really a juicy one
because in this video,
I'm going to tell you exactly
how much you will earn
in consulting if you work for an MBB firm,
if you work for a Big 4,
a Tier 2 management consulting firm,
including regional differences,
in the U.S., in Germany, in India,
in many other countries as well.
In addition, I have some precise numbers
on how the working hours differ
among McKinsey, BCG, Bain,
and also all the four Big 4 firms.
So if you're interested in this,
this video is right for you.
So when I come to
another coffee break here
on my channel Firm Learning.
I'm Heinrich,
I'm a former McKinsey consultant
and on my channel,
I talk about how to become successful
in the first years of your career.
So let's address the
elephant in the room first.
Where do I have all this data from?
Because surely this is not data
that is easily made
available to the public.
Here indeed a friend
of mine helped me out,
Mo Yang, who is running
"Consulting Humor."
He surveyed his audience,
which no surprise, consists
of lots of consultants
and thousands of people responded,
providing exact data on
what firm they work for,
where they work, what
their base salary is,
what their expected bonus is,
and many other information like this.
The data was collected
about three months ago,
so very recent and up-to-date.
But before we look at some numbers,
let me provide some important
remarks for you to understand
the data in the best possible way.
First, all data is self-reported.
People filled out the survey.
Of course, this comes
with some limitations,
the data was not verified in any way.
Indeed, I do wanna give
a shout-out to Mo Yang
from "Consulting Humor,"
who provided and collected all of this.
He has a huge Instagram account,
with lots of consulting
comedy and consulting memes.
So check him out.
I will link his socials below.
He also started on YouTube.
So I help him,
give him a subscribe as a
thank you for what he did here.
I do also wanna say
that I did only some
very limited data cleanup
on the whole table of
thousands of respondents.
So I took out some obvious entry errors,
some clear outliers that
just were not realistic,
but surely there will be
some wrong entries left.
Of course, last but not least,
I personally cannot vouch
for any specific data point
that I'm sharing.
This is what was sent
to me in the big table
that Mo Yang collected here.
And it surely was also not verified
with any of the large consulting firms.
All of this said, I do have
a little goodie for you.
And this is that I will provide
the full unedited dataset,
with thousands of data points,
the one that was also sent
to me, for you as a download.
So you'll find the download link
to this very big and extensive dataset
in the video description.
So if you wanna know what people earn
for a very specific firm
you are interested in,
in a very specific region.
Though I know, a big dataset,
it is in a pivot-table-friendly format.
So getting the insights that you need
is pretty straightforward.
Let's start with some basic
facts about the dataset.
So as you can see,
there are almost 4,000 people who provided
their information of which
consulting firm they work for.
The dataset is dominated
by people working in MBB
or in Big 4, which I guess is no surprise,
but which is also the reason
why I'm going to focus
on these firms in this video.
Whenever you talk about salaries,
it is important to
acknowledge that, of course,
there are very significant
regional differences.
Also, when working for the same firm,
the salary that you will
learn if you work in the U.S.
or in India and Germany
will significantly change.
As you can see here,
the dataset is biased towards the U.S.
They will show you also
some slices of the data
with averages per country
to make these differences visible as well.
Before we jump into salary,
let's talk about working hours
because this survey also
contained a question
on how long, on average,
the people worked in
their consulting firm.
I visualized this here
in this little heat map.
So as you can see, besides MBB and Big 4,
I also included Accenture,
EY-Partenon and Strategy&.
I included these additional ones
because those were companies
with more than 40 replies.
The dataset contains data for
many other companies as well.
Just feel free to download
it, link in video description,
if you are interested what the numbers are
for your specific firm.
So as you can see here,
for the MBB firms, for
McKinsey, BCG, and Bain,
they gravitate towards 60
to 69 hours, on average,
in terms of weekly working time.
McKinsey seems to be a
bit more on the upper end,
though the differences do
not seem too significant.
The Big 4 firms do seem
to be quite similar.
So, on average,
they seem to work a bit
less than the MBB firms,
with the main range about
40 till 60 hours per week.
Accenture seems to be more
comparable to the Big 4
and then EY-Parthenon and Strategy&
more to the strategy consulting firms,
which makes, of course, sense.
From my personal experience,
having actually worked at
Accenture for about half a year
as an intern during university,
these numbers do seem very plausible
and the same is true for MBB as well.
Obviously, please let
me know in the comments
whether you agree that this is
how your situation looks like
if you work for any of
these specific firms.
But let's now start with the salary data
and let's start with the graduates.
So the data for those people
who just started their career
in consulting, maybe are in
their first or second year.
To read these tables correctly,
we always have the
average base salary first.
Then you have the average bonus.
Here the people were asked
what their expected bonus was
for the last full 12 months.
This means that if you're
really a high performer
who performs above average,
you will likely earn even more.
But if you perform below average,
your bonus might be smaller than this.
It is worthwhile to notice
though that in some countries
and some firms,
you get also additional
compensation components.
This might, for instance,
be a company car,
which is very common in Germany,
or might also be, for instance,
health insurance benefits
or other insurance benefits.
Last but not least,
on the right you can see how
the total compensation differs
by U.S., India and Germany.
I chose these three countries
because from our audience analytics,
I know that these are the
countries with the most viewers
here on the Firm Learning channel.
So I trust you can read
the numbers for yourself.
Feel free to pause the video
for some additional seconds
to process all the data.
When looking at the total
compensation of the MBB firms,
you will see that these
are rather similar,
here with the one outlier, Bain.
This you can see, it's
only eight data points.
I looked into the raw data here.
The main reason is that there
are lots of people from India.
So if you look at the total
compensation by country,
you can see that then, for
the individual countries,
the compensation is quite similar indeed.
Same is true for the Big 4.
So the compensation
values are rather similar,
with KPMG being a negative outlier.
Here, once again,
lots of people from Asia
replying here for KPMG.
If you look at the country split,
you can again see that the Big
4 salaries are rather similar
here on the entry level.
By the way, when a number is
missing in the country split,
this just means that I only
had a handful of data points.
I felt this was then just
not valid to include,
but if you're interested in it, again,
you can download the
full unfiltered dataset
via the link in the video description
to then look at this data as well.
Next, let's look at the salary
data for young professionals.
So people being in consulting
for about one to three years or so.
Again, you can read all
the numbers for yourself.
There is one thing though
that I would like to stress,
especially for the MBB firms,
so McKinsey, BCG, Bain.
And this is their leave program.
So in almost all regions,
these MBB firms will
offer you an opportunity,
to after two or three years or so,
take a break from consulting
to pursue an MBA or a PhD
or similar relevant project.
These contributions can easily be worth
one or two additional annual salaries.
So from everything I understand,
the value of these leave
programs is not properly factored
into the salary data here,
but I do know that the attractiveness
of these leave programs
differed significantly,
also within the MBB firms,
which was also one of the reasons,
when I decided to join the
firm which you know I joined.
So make sure to research properly
what this leave program looks like.
And, here, also be aware that
even within the same firm,
depending on the region,
these programs can look quite differently.
Last but not least,
the salaries for more
seasoned consultants,
so for the project leads,
you will typically reach this level
after three to five years or so,
depending on how fast you get promoted
and on what level exactly you started.
At this level,
the salary gap of working
at McKinsey or BCG compared
to Bain will thus slowly
start to seem to open up,
whereas on the Big 4 end,
it does seem to still be quite homogenous.
Overall, we're looking
at the regional trends.
We can see that the U.S.
salaries are highest.
But these, of course,
do also come with likely
the highest living costs
if you're based in coastal cities,
on the East Coast or the West Coast.
Then you have the situation in Germany,
probably comparing Germany
to some other countries in the EU.
Germany likely is on the
upper end of the salaries
that you will get.
So if you work, for instance,
in Spain or Italy, your
salaries are likely going to be
a little bit smaller.
Again, you can look at this
yourself in the full dataset.
And then, of course,
salaries in India and also
some other Asian countries
will be significantly lower.
So I do hope you found this insightful,
and I would love to hear
from you in the comments,
based on your experience,
are these numbers accurate?
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and subscribe to this
channel to stay up-to-date
on all the content.
Also a big shout-out to "Consulting Humor"
for putting all of this together.
I trust the dataset is
extremely insightful.
If you wanna download the full thing,
link to it in the video description.
A big thank you to all the
members supporting this channel.
My name is Heinrich from Firm Learning.
I release new videos
every single Saturday.
So see you soon again next week.
Until then, bye bye.